[Musique]
voir ou revoir votre
programme sur
publicsena.fr tout de suite sur public
[Musique]
SNA tu ne dois pas laisser les femmes
s'asseoir dans ta voiture si elle ne
cach pas leur
visage les adultes ont peur des talibans
les animaux ont peur des talibans et
même les bébés ont peur des talents je
voudrais savoir qu'est-ce qui leur
arrive qu'est-ce qui se passe quand il
voi une femme que je fais un entretien
on me dit que je ne peux pas être
embauché parce que je suis une femme
mais être une femme n'est pas un
péché les talibans m'ont arrêté et m'ont
dit que je devais porter un masque et me
couvrir les cheveux correctement je leur
ai répondu que je ne porterai pas de
masque et que je ne le porterai jamais
si je demain je mourrais fier d'être
resté avec les femmes d'Afghanistan
jusqu'au dernier jour de ma
vie afghan un documentaire exceptionnel
samedi à 21h sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat bonjour à tous très heureux de
vous retrouver ici en direct de la Porte
de Versailles à Paris pour ce 105e
congrès des maires de France organisé
par la MF l'Association des maires de
France Public Sénat continue à vous
faire vivre l'événement et à décrypter
les préoccupations de nos élus locaux
dans 30 minutes nous parlerons avec mes
invités de la hausse des violences
contre les élus c'est le sujet majeur
cette année de ce congrès des maires de
France mais avant je vous propose
d'écouter Gabriel Atal le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui a répondu ce
matin aux questions des maire notamment
sur la laïcité à l'école c'était très
important pour moi de pouvoir être là je
veux vous remercier remercier le
président de l'Association des maires de
France David lissnard avec qui je dois
dire j'entretiens un travail extrêmement
constructif dans une grande franchise
depuis ma nomination au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
évidemment je souhaite que nous
puissions poursuivre au fond dans dans
les sujets que vous avez évoqué et dans
euh les déplacements que je peux faire
et dans la vie de chacune et de chacun
d'entre vous on le voit
notre école est traversée par un certain
nombre de mots notre société est
traversée par un certain nombre de mots
et moi je crois profondément que dans
des périodes comme celles que nous
vivons il faut toujours en revenir à
l'essentiel et en revenir à l'essentiel
sur le rôle de l'école de la République
la mission de l'école de la République
c'est de former des républicains et de
démocratiser le savoir c'est ça
l'essentiel de ce que nous attendons de
l'école et de ce que notre pays doit
attendre de l'école et je le dis de ce
point de vue-là l'accomplissement de
cette mission ne peut-être réussi que si
nous travaillons ensemble que s'il y a
une alliance profonde entre les
collectivités locales et singulièrement
les communes et l'État c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça que l'école et la République se
sont construits les lois guizo qui
d'ailleurs était d'une très grande
modernité reste d'une très grande
modernité qui prévoyait déjà que des
équipement puissent être regroupé
parlait pas d'intercommunalité à
l'époque ont déjà prévu ce travail là et
si l'école de la République a pu se
construire c'est grâce aussi aux
communes aux maires aux élus qui se sont
engagés si on veut pouvoir réussir sur
l'ensemble de ces enjeux il faut qu'on
puisse avancer ensemble parce que le
temps de l'enfant un enfant ne se
découpe pas en ne se découpe pas tout
court d'abord mais ce ne se découte pas
en temps évidemment qu'il y a le temps
scolaire le temps périscolaire le temps
familial mais s'il n'y a pas un égal
investissement et des objectifs partagés
sur l'ensemble de ces temps tout le
travail qui est mené dans un cadre
scolaire finalement peut-être réduit à
néant s'il n'y a pas un égal
investissement ailleurs et ça marche
dans tous les sens et ça vaut pour tous
les sujets quand on parle d'émancipation
sociale quand on parle d'élévation du
niveau quand on parle de lutte contre le
harcèlement quand on parle de sécurité
tout ça participe d'un continuum qu'on
doit être capable de construire ensemble
et moi je veux dire que de tous les
échanges que j'ai avec les maires sur le
terrain de tous les échanges que j'ai
avec vos représentants je suis
extrêmement confiant et optimiste sur
notre capacité à relever tous ces défis
ça nécessite quoi ça nécessite
évidemment une adaptation locale et
évidemment que tous les territoires ne
sont pas confrontés aux mêmes
difficultés comme c'est la question les
questions auxquelles j'ai assisté en
arrivant je vais y répondre directement
évidemment que nos territoires
ultramarins justifie qu'on a une action
spécifique et les élèves les familles
les écoles sont confrontés à des enjeux
qu'on trouve dans l'Hexagone mais
multiplié par 10 par 100 ou par 1000
s'agissant de la précarité s'agissant
des enjeux et des difficultés scolaires
qui peuvent concerner nos jeunes et nos
enfants mais je vois aussi à chaque fois
que je me déplace dans ces territoires
des signes d'espoir on arrive à faire
des choses donz l'exemple de Mayotte
évidemment territoire extrêmement
difficile d'un point de vue social d'un
point de vue migratoire d'un point de
vue économique d'un point de vue
scolaire qu'est-ce qu'on a fait à maot
ces dernières années qui nous éclaire
d'ailleurs dans les travaux que je suis
en train de mener sur l'élévation du
niveau de nos élèves et je ferai des
annonces au début du mois de décembre on
a mis en place le manuel scolaire unique
à l'école primaire pour l'apprentissage
de la lecture et de l'écriture qu'est-ce
qu'on a vu comme résultat une réduction
de 30 à 40 points de l'écart dans
l'entrée dans la lecture entre les
élèves Maorais et la moyenne nationale
on voit qu'on peut faire des choses sur
le créol je suis totalement d'accord et
je sais que mon ministère ces dernières
années o en tout cas dans une position
historique n'a pas été on va dire le
plus allant sur la reconnaissance des
langues régionales moi je crois
profondément aux langues régionales
d'abord je pense que c'est notre
patrimoine c'est Notre culture c'est
notre histoire ça doit pouvoir être
transmis à nos enfants et j'y crois
aussi dans un dans une logique de
performance scolaire c'est un non sens
d'imaginer que dans un territoire où 85
% des enfants parlent créole à la maison
en ayant uniquement du français à
l'école ils vont pouvoir apprendre dans
de bonnes conditions et là aussi on a
innové et on a vu un certain nombre de
résultats à la Réunion on a mis en place
des classe bilangue français CRÉO on a
expérimenté ça en
maternel quand on compare une classe
bilang français créole en maternel à la
réunion avec une classe 100 % français
on constate que les élèves qui sont
passés par la classe français créole
parlent mieux français que les élèves
qui étaient dans la classe 100 %
français bah oui et donc moi je crois
beaucoup à cette méthode là et à cette
adaptation au niveau local et donc je
vais insister sur deux points de méthode
et deux éléments de méthode qui me
semblent importants d'abord le travail
qui est en train d'être mené sur la
capacité à avoir une projection sur du
plus long terme sur la carte scolaire
parce que la carte scolaire qui tombe
chaque année sans concertation avec les
élus et qui annoncent des fermetures de
classe c'est juste pas possible ça nuit
profond ment à la confiance des citoyens
de la communauté éducative envers les
pouvoirs publics tous les pouvoirs
publics et donc ce qui a été annoncé par
la première ministre qui est en train de
se mettre en œuvre au niveau local et
croyez bien que j'attache une importance
toute particulière à ce que ce soit
véritablement mis en place c'est une
instance qui permettra en concertation
entre les élus locaux et les services de
l'éducation nationale d'avoir des
projections démographiques partagées et
de partager un calendrier et de partager
des projections sur 3 ans sur les
ouvertures et fermetures de classe ça me
semble essentiel pour retisser la confi
deè élément de méthode très important le
CNR Conseil national de la refondation
sur l'école appelé dans l'éducation
nationale notre école faisons là
ensemble qui est pour moi une vraie
révolution dans l'organisation et le
fonctionnement du ministère l'éducation
nationale c'est pas uniquement levier de
financement de dispositif pour les
élèves c'est un changement de d'état
d'esprit c'est une révolution
copernicienne pour l'école l'idée c'est
de dire qu'on doit au niveau local dans
chaque école voir la communauté
éducative et je mets évidemment les élus
locaux dedans en capacité de faire un
diagnostic sur ce qui fonctionne et ce
qui ne fonctionne pas d'identifier des
besoins pour les élèves et d'être
soutenu y compris financièrement pour
développer des projets c'est un
remarquable succès quantitatif 11000
projets qui ont été remontés au
ministère 4600 qui ont été validés à
chaque fois que je me déplace je vois de
très belles réussites j'étais encore à
saintoness dans l'héau il y a quelques
jours des enseignants qui se sont dit
voilà on a des problèmes en mathématique
école primaire on veut mettre en place
un labo de math avec des dispositifs
innovants sur les mathématiques pour nos
enfants on fait notre projet on est
soutenu 30000 € du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale pour financer le
projet on a une académie un ministère
qui n'est plus là simplement pour
contrôler mais qui est là pour
accompagner qui n'est pas là pour
sanctionner mais qui est là pour
conseiller c'est une vraie révolution et
je sais que si ça a été un succès
quantitatif d'un point de vue qualitatif
notamment sur la participation des des
élus locaux à ces travaux-là on peut
faire mieux voilà on a eu l'occasion de
se le dire avec la représentant des élus
locaux donc c'est la consigne que j'ai
donné à mes service je vais pas être
beaucoup plus long pour pouvoir prendre
les questions mais au
fond l'école et la mairie c'est une
histoire profondément partagé d's on
voit partout dans notre pays des mairies
écoles encore lois guiso et il nous
appartient tous ensemble de continuer à
écrire cette histoire ensemble au
service de la formation des républicains
de la démocratisation du savoir tout
simplement au service de la République
merci beaucoup merci Gabriel Atal
alors pour vous faciliter le le travail
je vais vous proposer de de procéder par
salve de de questions ou de remarques
par salve de TR ça vous va ce rythme
trinitaire monsieur
bonjour bonjour monsieur le ministre et
bon
courage à vous répondre
oui je je suis le maire de Loris dans le
voclus vous connaissez pas mais vous
connaissez Lmin à côté c'est à 5
km et en plus la je veux pas vous
embêter cette question
dépend pas tellement de vous j'étais
travailleur social éducateur spécialisé
dans les quartiers nord de Marseille où
j'ai passé 30 ans et j'ai vu partir les
éducateurs spécialisés de prévention
spécialisé j'ai vu partir les animateurs
les assant sociales fermer les maisons
des jeunes j'aurais d bon donc je vais
réduire la nature à horreur du vide
après il y a eu une école au qui faisait
du soutien scolaire normal traditionnel
souple tranquille il y a rien à dire
mais après il y a deux écoles coraniques
par cité il y en a qui font du
prosélitisme ça dépend pas de vous mais
c'est c'est quand même tout se tient on
est dans tout
donc la nature hereure du vide il faut
pas laisser des intégristes prendre la
place du soutien
scolaire
merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers mes chers
collègues maires et élus Dominique
Fouchier le maire de Tournefeuille dans
l'agglomération toulousain 29000
habitants 2800 élèves scolarisés
monsieur le ministre je voulais vous
interpeller sur la scolarisation des
enfants hébergés par le 115 nous avons
eu à scolariser à Tournefeuille 80
enfants comp tenu du fait que deux
hôtels deux résidence hôtelière s'était
spécialisé dans l'hébergement
d'urgence l'école est un angle mort pour
l'éber d'urgence et l'hébergement
d'urgence est un angle mort pour l'école
nous avons aucune information préalable
aucune préparation aucun moyen
supplémentaire si ce n'est quelques
quelques horaires quelques heures mises
à disposition par par vos services nous
avons des difficultés évidemment
financière dans l'accompagnement social
humanitaire sur la restauration des
questions de santé se posent des
questions d'assurance scolaire se posent
monsieur le ministre il est urgent
d'agir parce que c'est une question
d'humanité je vous remercie merci à vous
Gabriel Atal 3è intervention la dernière
de cette première
salve bonjour monsieur le ministre
bonjour chers collègues euh je m'appelle
Claire guerou je suis mère d'une petite
commune de 1000 habitants en scène
maritime et vice-président du
département ma question va être très
simple mes parents sont nés en 31 en 35
ils ont tous les deux arrêté l'école à
14 ans certificat d'études ils ont pas
fait de formation derrière ils savent
tous les deux lire écrire correctement
sans faute d'orthographe ils savent
compter qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour que pour
que pour que finissez votre phrase je
vous en prie je pense que je pense que
c'est c'est clair la suite aujourd'hui
on sait très bien qu' un gamin de 20 ans
de 15 ans même même 30 ans des fois n
incapable de faire une phrase sans faire
10 fautes d'orthographe il ne sait pas
compter de tête enfin connait plus
cétable de multiplication voilà quoi
donc il a un moment il y a un truc qui
s'est passé j'aimerais savoir quoi à
quel moment ça a dérapé
merci beaucoup madame on le demande à un
je alors merci beaucoup pour ces trois
questions qui sont trois questions très
importantes d'abord je vous rejoint
totalement si
euh l'école les services publics d'une
manière générale qui permettre
l'émancipation de nos enfants laisse de
l'espace l'espace est pris par d'autres
et notamment par l'islamisme que vous
avez évoqué dont on a vu dramatiquement
à à race combien il gardait notrec comme
ennemi
principal les islamistes ils en veulent
à notre école pourquoi ils en veulent à
notre école parce que notre école elle
est ouverte à tous et que eux
souhaiteraient garder le plus éloigné
possible du savoir le plus grand nombre
possible pour pouvoir imposer leur
doctrine ils en veulent à notre école
parce qu'elle est mixte or leur projet
est de laisser les petites filles les
femmes en dehors du savoir ils en
veulent à notre école parce qu'elle est
laïque or leur projet c'est d'imposer la
loi de la religion plutôt que la loi de
la République et donc ça justifie et ça
nécessite qu'on réaffirme de manière
extrêmement forte nos principes et nos
valeurs ce que j'ai fait dès ma prise de
fonction s'agissant du respect de la loi
de 2004 puisqu'il ne s'agit que de ça
sur la BAA et le camis en milieu
scolaire et on voit qu'on a réussi à
faire appliquer cette décision et qui ne
sont aujourd'hui plus porté ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'on est au bout des
problèmes de laïcité et des atteintes à
la laïcité à l'école évidemment je
continue à travailler sur ce sujet donc
oui il faut renforcer la présence
éducative auprès de nos jeunes il faut
la la renforcer à tous les niveaux c'est
aussi pour ça que j'ai pris des
décisions s'agissant du calendrier
scolaire pour aller au bout le plus
possible au bout du calendrier scolaire
en décalant les épreuves de spécialité
du baccalauréat de mars à juin en
faisant en sorte que toutes les épreuves
soient le plus tard possible en juin en
demandant que les conseils de classe
soient le plus tard possible dans le
mois de juin en mettant en place pour la
première fois et ça sera un enjeu très
fort faudra tous qu'on se mobilise un
stage de 2 semaines pour les élèves de
seconde pour que jusqu'à la fin du mois
de juin eux aussi ils soient en
formation on arrive là cette année 2023-
2024 à la fameuse reconquête du mois de
juin dont on parle compris pour nos
collégiens puisque pour la première fois
j'ai décidé que le brevet aurait lieu en
juillet ce qui veut dire que les
collégiens seront en classe jusqu'au
dernier jour de juin c'est très
important reconquérir du temps aussi
dans la journée on a aujourd'hui 200
collèges qui expérimentent le 8h 18h des
collèges de quartier politique de la
ville avec un accompagnement pour les
devoirs
avec plus de sport plus de culture les
élèves sont accueillis de 8h à 18h
septembre prochain on va généraliser
l'accueil 8h 18h au collège à tous les
quartiers politiques de la ville
évidemment c'est une logique qu'on va
souhaiter ensuite poursuivre et étendre
parce qu'on doit davantage être présent
et accompagner les jeunes notamment sur
les devoirs c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a
mis en place devoir fait qui permet à
des élèves de pouvoir faire leur devoirs
dans un cadre scolaire et on est en
train de le généraliser aussi donc je
vous rejoins sur la question des
animateurs c'est vrai moi je me réjouis
de voir que l'an dernier on a eu 37 % de
jeunes formés en plus au BAFA par eu
aussi un soutien financier
supplémentaire de l'État parce qu'on a
baisser l'âge à 16 ans on sait que pour
la filière animation c'est absolument
essentiel et ensuite il y a tout le
travail de fermeture d'établissement
qu'on doit continuer à assumer et à
engager moi j'ai été très frappé d'un
déplacement que j'ai fait ça remonte un
peu dans un une ville que je ne citerit
pas pas stigmatisé mais une école
absolument remarquable école primaire
qui incarne tout ce qu'on a fait pour
ces l'école de ces quartiers depuis 2017
toutes les classes dédoublées petit-
dééjeuner gratuit servi à tous les
élèves le matin professeurs d'une très
grande qualité on a revalorisé leur
prime l'école avait été intégralement
refaite par la commune d'ailleurs je
vois la directrice je lui dis ça doit
être absolument formidable pour les
élèves elle me dit c'était formidable au
début mais il y a une association qui a
ouvert qui fait soi-disant de l'accueil
au devoir le mercredi et le weekend mais
qui en réalité lave le cerveau des
enfants et on n jamais eu autant de
déscolarisation et de désinscription de
de l'école d'enfants soit-disant ensuite
en instruction en famille mais qui en
réalité on le sait sont scolarisés de
manière clandestine dans cette école là
d'où l'importance de ce qu'on a fait sur
l'instruction en famille depuis pour
réduire au maximum les dévoiements et
d'où ce qu'on doit continuer à faire
pour fermer ces établissements je passe
assez vite sur donc deuxème question oui
évidemment c'est absolument majeur il y
a deux publics on va dire extrêmement
vulnérable pour lesquels on le sait
aujourd'hui on n'est pas au niveau de ce
qu'on doit faire en matière de
scolarisation c'est les enfants placés
ouis les enfants de laazu et
effectivement les enfants qui sont
hébergés dans l'hébergement d'urgence
sur les enfants placés j'ai annoncé en
début de semaine dans le cadre du comité
interministériel à l'enfance des
dispositifs pour arriver à une vraie
scolarité protégée et sur l'hébergement
d'urgence c'est ce qu'on est en train de
mener on aura l'année prochaine un
moment important à la rentrée prochaine
puisque tous les enfants sur le sol
national bénéficieront désormais d'un
numéro INE qui est l'identifiant
éducation nationale pour chaque élève ça
paraît tout ça comme ça très
administratif peut-être même anecdotique
mais ça l''est pas du tout ça va
vraiment simplifier le partage
d'information et la capacité à
scolariser aussi vite que possible des
élèves qui sont des enfants qui sont
dans l'hébergement d'urgence il y a
probablement d'autres mesures à inventer
moi je suis très ouvert pour qu'on
puisse y travailler ensemble avec les
élus qui sont les plus confrontés à ces
situations enfin très dur de répondre à
votre où
êtes-vous d'accord très dur de répondre
à votre question en quelques instant
mais moi je considère que c'est le cœur
de la mission qui est la mienne élever
le niveau général et élever le niveau
assumer qu'on a le droit de viser une
certaine excellence et une exigence pour
nos élèves en 2018 un élève de 4e avait
le niveau d'un élève de 5e de 1995 en 23
ans on a perdu 1 an de
niveau j'ai présenté la semaine dernière
les résultats des évaluations nationales
qu'on réalise désormais et on le doit
notamment à Jean-Michel Blanquer qui
avait mis en place ses évaluations CP
CE1 CM1 6e 4 seconde on a des
évaluations nationales ce qui permet de
savoir le niveau individuel de chacun et
de personnaliser les apprentissages et
d'avoir une photographie du niveau
général que nous disent ces évaluations
d'abord il y a un signe d'espoir je
pense c'est toujours important de
regarder aussi ça sinon on fait tous
autre chose si on croyait pas qu'on
pouvait changer les choses on ferait
tous différemment en tout cas moi ça
serait mon mon cas je sais que pour vous
aussi je fais partie des quelques
membres du gouvernement qui sont élus
locaux je suis conseiller municipal dans
ma commune depuis 10 ans je sais ce que
donnent les élus locaux les maires sur
le on croit qu'on peut changer les
choses et on le voit on a fait une
énorme priorité depuis 2017 pour l'école
primaire notamment sur la lecture
l'écriture et le calcul et notamment
pour les quartiers les plus difficiles
où il y a le plus d'écart qu'est-ce
qu'on voit que tout l'investissement qui
a été mis depuis 2017 pour le premier
degré qui est inédit dans notre histoire
commence à porter ses fruits il y avait
en 2017 un élève sur 3 qui rentrer en 6e
sans savoir lire écrire et compter
correctement on est là en 2023 à 1/ qu
alors ça reste beaucoup trop mais enfin
on voit que pour la première fois depuis
très longtemps ça s'améliore et que la
génération 2017 celle qui entrait en CP
quand le président de la République a
été élu et qu'on a réinvesti massivement
sur le primaire et qui rentre en 6e
cette année elle s'en sort mieux que la
génération 2012 et la génération 2007 ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut
poursuivre et notamment poursuivre au
collège parce que là on a vu les
résultat absolument édifiant on voit que
le collège ne parvient pas à réduire les
écarts qu'on constate à l'entrée en 6e
en 4e songez bien qu'un élève sur 4 n'a
pas le niveau attendu en lecture pour un
élève de CM2 de
CM2 donc j'ai lancé un travail depuis 2
mois de concertation avec les
enseignants et d'ailleurs je veux saluer
250000 enseignants qui ont répondu au
questionnaires que j'ai envoyé avec les
organisations syndicales avec un certain
nombre d'experts j'annoncerai le 5
décembre des mesures pour élever le
niveau et notamment pour investir
massivement sur le collège et je le dis
je n'ai aucun un tabout j'ai ouvert un
certain nombre de débats j'ai vu que ça
faisait débat notamment certaines
organisations syndicales qui s'y
opposaient et notamment la question de
groupe de niveau en français et en
mathématique au collège je le dis mais
parce que les enseignants me le disent
sur le terrain on ne peut plus avoir
dans la même classe en français en
mathématique des élèves qui savent
parfaitement lire et des élèves qui ne
savent pas lire puisqueà la fin plus
personne ne progresse et ça tire tout le
monde vers le bas donc moi j'assume de
dire qu'on doit revoir notre
organisation si on veut vraiment élever
le niveau général c'est ça la mission de
l'école c'est ma mission donc pour
répondre à votre question qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé moi je suis pas là pour
donner des leçons au passé à mes
prédécesseur je suis là pour regarder de
l'avant et je crois profondément parce
que c'est ce qu'on est en train de voir
notamment à l'entrée en 6e qu'on peut
redresser la Baras on peut reprendre les
choses en main et c'est vous l'aurez
compris ce que je souhaite faire dans
les mois à venir merci merci il est
12h23 cher public cher public il est
12h23 on a 7 minutes encore avec
Monsieur le Ministre d'après son cabinet
moi j'ai plus de temps si vous voulez
alors faudrait que le cabinet alors
madame tout d'abord et Monsieur ensuite
et puis une troisème question pour la
parité j'égaliserai les chos bonjour
monsieur le ministre un grand merci de
d'être parmi nous donc Maria passe VO là
ici oui là ici
donc donc je suis maduante d'une toute
petite commune dans la périphérie des
des Dijon et donc je vous remercie de
Monsieur parce que je suis aussi
professeur d'espagnol à Dijon même donc
je vous remercie de tout les messieurs
que vous nous avez brillamment résumé
pour les secondaire en ce qui concerne
voilà les calendriers scolaires la la
reconquête des mois de juin mais je
voudrais simplement ici en tant que
représentante d'une tout petite commune
parce que je pense qu'ici on est tous on
est la grande majorité des des des
maires qui sont ici ou des adjoints sont
des tout petites communes des voilà des
simplement vous demander qu'est-ce que
l'éducation nationale peut faire pour
que nous puissions améliorer la qualité
de notre service péricolaire parce qu'
une grande différence nous qui on est en
périurbaine entre les servic qui propose
la la ville de Dijon et que nous on peut
on peut proposer par manque de moyens
simplement et aussi une petite précision
pour finir c'est par rapport à les SSH
évidemment que les statut des s il
doitchanger évidemment que les statut
des s il doit être complété par des
servic dans les dans les P pers
scolaires mais moi je parle ici
maintenant des publics de l'école
publique et laïque donc et c'est un
grand effort dans nos petites communes
de faire porter sur nous les
financements de cette voilà de cette
partie de de de la rémunération des S je
vous remercie beaucoup merci Monsieur le
Ministre derrière vous s'il vous plaît
derrière vous bonjour monsieur bonjour
monsieur le ministre bonjour cher maire
euh Flavien foué donc je suis CPE au
collège dans une commune à en Guyane à
grand senantier plus précisément et ma
question c'est plutôt autour des des
moyens dans les établissements scolaires
alors nous en terme d'équipement euh à
la mairie nous sommes très très bien
accompagné euh par les services de
l'État mais euh la le le problème se
pose plutôt euh au niveau des
enseignants à la rentrée là euh pour les
vacances de toussin quand nous sommes
partis nous avions encore beaucoup euh
de classes dans les écoles où il y avait
pas de professeurs nommés et où les
élèves étaient euh encore à la maison
euh même à la rentrée de novembre nous
avions encore ces problèmes-là alors
c'est vrai que euh les communes du
fleuve sont compliqué parce que très
isolé et euh difficulté d'accès mais euh
plus généralement ma question euh
rejoint à la question qui a été posée
par la collègue concernant le niveau des
élèves on se rend compte que les élèves
sur le fleuve cumulent beaucoup de
difficultés mais il manque des moyens
pour les accompagner notamment les les
les PS ou les personnes pour
détecter les difficultés des élèves et
justement les mettre dans les bons
dispositifs monsieur je vous en prie
merci Monsieur le Ministre bonjour je
suis Gael Souché moi je suis adjint
maire en fait sur la ville de saintgrève
en en iser nous avons peu près 1500 en
enfan scolarisé 67 classes je je
rebondis sur ce que vous parlez tout à
l'heure sur la la carte scolaire et
cette idée de planification que je
trouve intéressante euh et et ça
pourrait être aussi intéressant
peut-être d'aller au-delà euh dans les
écoles en fait on on prend notre part à
à à cette planification et notamment
cette transition dans la rénovation
énergétique dans la désimpermisation des
sols dans les cours d'école on a
commencé nous des projets où on en fait
une par an et et et pour aller justement
dans cette dans cette idée aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'on a rencontré notre i
dans une logique un peu comptable où
elle est venu nous voir dis voilà vous
avez 67 classes avec une moyenne qu'on
calcule il faudrait éventuellement
fermer CIN classes alors évidemment on a
négocié on était pas d'accord euh et et
et c'est plus aussi dans cette idée de
nous on va investir est-ce que vous
auriez aussi la possibilité d'investir
pour l'avenir nos enfants c'est l'avenir
l'avenir c'est nos enfants de se dire
aussi ben l'investissement il peut aussi
se faire du côté éducation nationale en
évitant peut-être parfois de fermer des
classes euh pour avoir des des classes
moins chargées euh donc maintenir ce ce
niveau d'enseignant finalement et sortir
un peu de cette logique des fois un peu
comptable pour permettre non seulement
peut-être d'avoir des classements chargé
partout qui permettra aussi peut-être
d'arriver peut-être à améliorer ce ce
fameux niveau qu'on veut remonter et
puis aussi avoir ce réservoir aussi
d'enseignants puisqueon a aussi cette
difficulté parfois d'avoir des
enseignants et des remplacements
d'enseignants quand on a des absences
qui durent un peu longtemps et c'est
également une difficulté voilà je vous
remercie merci Gabriel altal il est
12h28 j'ai encore une deux questions et
plein d'autres que souhaitez-vous faire
mais je sais pas on a la salle jusqu'à
12 45 13 bon ben très bien ben on va on
peut aller jusqu'à 12 je vois mon
cabinet qui s'agite en disant que ça a
l'air compliqué maiset non mais on peut
prendre on peut reprendre de de je donc
trois questions là vous les avez noté et
après une nouvelle séquence comme ça bon
euh sur le le périscolaire j'ai dit tout
à l'heure notamment ce qu'on faisait en
matière d'investissement pour la
formation d'animateur parce que je sais
que c'est un problème pour beaucoup de
communes et ce qu'on a réussi à faire je
crois l'an dernier sur le BAFA il faut
qu'on continue à à le porter pour que
vous puissiez avoir davantage de de
davantage outillés en terme humain pour
le faire sur les aesh bon l'école
inclusive c'est un enjeu absolument
majeur aujourd'hui et je le sais partout
sur le terrain là aussi on a quand même
fait un certain nombre de progrès depuis
2017 on accueille beaucoup plus d'élèves
475000 élèves en situation de handicap
qui sont accueillis parce qu'on a
recruté beaucoup d'Es c'est c'est
désormais le deuxième métier de
l'éducation nationale elles sont
135000 on a fait des progrès donc d'un
point de vue quantitatif maintenant il
faut qu'on arrive à faire des progrès
d'un point de vue qualitatif sur la
qualité de l'accueil moi je le dis je
suis préoccupé quand je me déplace que
j'échange avec des professeurs des
écolees des directeurs d'école par
parfois l'épuisement la difficulté le
sentiment d'être dépassé par l'accueil
d'élèves en situation de de de handicap
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on continue à
recruter pour les accompagner
continue à déprécariser aussi le métier
d'aesh je rappelle qu'en 2017 les Aes
étaient recrutés sur des contrats assez
précaires en contrat aidé en cette
rentrée on en a 60 % qui sont en CDI on
les a augmenté à la rentrée de 10 à 13 %
ce qui fait sur un salaire de 800 € par
mois en moyenne évidemment peu donc tout
l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à ce qu'ell
puisse faire davantage d'heur et faire
un temps complet pour améliorer leur
rémunération et c'est notamment sur le
temps de la pause méridienne qu'on peut
y arriver moi je suis assez tenu je dois
le dire par la décision du Conseil
d'État sur le sujet qui dit que ça n'est
pas le financement par l'État sur ce
temps-là mais que c'est le financement
par les collectivités local donc je suis
conscient des difficultés il faut qu'on
arrive à signer des conventions au
niveau local et il y en a déjà plusieurs
dizaines qui ont été signées entre
l'éducation nationale et les commune et
parfois on arrive en adaptant les choses
à faire en sorte qu'il ait quand même de
manière un peu détournée ou indirecte un
soutien de l'État sur ce sujet-là mais
il faut qu'on y arrive parce que c'est
bon pour les Aes en terme de
rémunération et c'est comme ça qu'on
arrivera à les fidéliser c'est bon pour
les élèves handicapés parce que c'est
absurde d'avoir à l'heure du déjeuner
des ah qui ne sont pas en temps de
travail et pas rémunéré et des élèves à
la cantine qui auraient besoin d'un
accompagnement avec une personne formée
qui n'ont pas toujours une personne
vraiment formé pour les accompagner donc
il faut qu'on arrive à déployer ces
conventions et nous en tout cas on est
très ouvert mes services c'est la
consigne que je leur ai donné adapter
les choses pour que ça soit le plus
facile possible pour les communes y
compris d'un point de vue financier même
si encore une fois on est tenu par une
décision de justice on va continuer à
avancer notamment on va développer dans
l'éducation nationale une coltique
consistant à dire qu'onattend
plus la notification de la MDPH pour
adapter l'accompagnement et le matériel
pédagogique parce que parfois c'est 8
mois 10 mois avant qu'il a la
notification et donc là on va à partir
de l'année prochaine expérimenter des
pôles d'appui à la scolarité o en gros
l'éducation nationale pourra décider
d'un adaptation pédagogique d'un
accompagnement sans attendre la
notification MDPH ça je pense que pour
les familles ça va être plus simple
c'est pôle d'appuie à la scolarité ça
sera aussi un guichet unique pour les
accompagner dans leur démarche y compris
avec la MDPH parce que ça peut être très
compliqué je pense par ailleurs qu'on
peut encore simplifier les démarches
côté mdphage que les familles a pas
régulièrement à à devoir y retourner
faut progresser mais je le dis c'est un
enjeu majeur parce que je ne voudrais
pas que certains politiquement notamment
du côté des extrêmes cherchent à
prospérer sur ces difficultés qu'on
constate et c'est pas un sujet Fran
français l'extrême droite allemande lafd
a annoncé cet été qui mettait désormais
au cœur de leur projet politique le
rejet de l'école inclusive et on voit ce
mouvement dans un certain nombre de pays
moi je ne veux pas que des difficultés
qu'on constate sur le terrain deviennent
le Terrero pour certains qui
politiquement chercheraient à
instrumentaliser ces difficultés parce
que revenir en arrière pour l'école sur
l'école inclusive ça serait terrible
pour les enfants terrible pour les
familles et globalement terrible pour
l'école parce que le rôle de l'école
c'est de pouvoir accueillir tous les
élèves quel que soit leur difficulté ou
leur vulnérabilité
sur la question des des enseignants il y
a quatre académies on a le plus grand
nombre de difficultés à recruter
académie de Versailles créteille Mayotte
et guyan donc oui on a des vraies
difficultés on cherche évidemment y
répondre j'annoncerai en janvier une
réforme profonde de la formation initial
des enseignants ce qui à la fois un
enjeu d'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant parce que la formation
telle qu'elle est organ oranisé souvent
est un frein pour des jeunes qui ont
cette vocation de devenir enseignants
mais qui sont découragés par un concours
qui a été positionné à bac+ 5
par un accompagnement social pas
suffisamment fort il faut en revenir aux
écoles normales adapté au 21e siècle
avec la possibilité de prérecruter dès
le bac des jeunes qui ont envie de
devenir enseignants qui ont cette
vocation avec une vraie politique
sociale de les accompagner pendant 3 ans
à fond sur les fondamentaux le français
les mathématiques la laïcité un concours
à bac+ 3 et ensuite une entrée
progressive dans le métier sur 2 ans
voilà voilà pour cette intervention du
ministre de l'éducation nationale
Gabriel Attal au Congrès des Maires de
France c'était ce matin Gabriel Attal
qui a notamment annoncé qu'il prendrait
des mesures pour lutter contre la baisse
du niveau des élèves il promet de
s'attaquer je cite au tabou du
redoublement et des groupes de niveau
dans les classes place maintenant au
débat de cette émission qui est
consacrée à la hausse des violences
contre contre les élus avec ce chiffre
inquiétant 7 mèires sur 10 déclare avoir
été victime de violence verbale ou
physique selon une étude du svipof pour
en parler j'accueille ce soir sur ce
plateau Cécile cuckerman bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes sénatrice de la Loire et
présidente du groupe communiste au Sénat
j'accueille également André léel bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes premier vice-président
de la MF l'Association des maires de
France et maire socialiste disouddain
j'accueille également anne- Françoise
pieddalu bonsoir vous êtes maire de la
pressquille de plougrescamp dans les
Côtes d'Armor et puis bonsoir à vous
martial fouco bonsoir vous êtes
politologue et directeur du svipof le
centre de recherche de sciencep avant de
commencer nos échanges sur ce phénomène
de hausse de des violences contre les
élus on va faire le point avec ce sujet
de Fabien RER il était devenu le visage
de ces élus victimes de violence en mai
dernier Yannick morz maire de
Saint-Brévin les pains jette l'éponge
après l'incendie criminel contre son
domicile sa démission est la classe
politique s'en prendre à un élu quel que
soit son mandat quelle que soit son
étiquette c'est s'en prendre à la
République insulte menace sur les
réseaux sociaux ou agression physique le
phénomène est en constante augmentation
2265 faits de violence constaté l'an
dernier plus 32 % par rapport à 2021 et
déjà 2900 faits de violence signalé pour
l'année 2023 une tendance inquiétante
alimentée notamment par les émeutes de
cet été
mais aussi par une prise de conscience
et l'incitation faite aux élus à
signaler systématiquement les agressions
qu'ils subissent il n a pas de petite
menace donc on ne veut plus entendre
quand un élu
envisage de porter plainte que de toute
façon ça va être classé sans suite et
que que c'est donc pas la peine de
porter plainte donc là on est dans dans
une demande expresse de ne pas
considérer qu'il des petites ou moyennes
menac on porte plainte après le drame de
saintbrvin le gouvern ement a présenté
un plan de lutte contre les violences
avec un volet sécurité chaque élu local
devra notamment avoir accès à un
référent police ou gendarmerie auprès
duquel signaler une agression le plan
prévoit aussi d'alourdir les sanctions
pénales contre les auteurs de violence
pour l'Association des maires de France
la justice est encore trop lente pour
condamner les agresseurs nous ce qu'on
demande en tant qu'élu aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il y ait un suivi rapide lorsqu'il y
a une plainte déposée par un élu ce qui
est pas forcément aujourd'hui le cas et
et lorsquon discute avec les différents
procureurs ils nous disent mais nous
nous avons un problème de moyen et et
donc ça c'est pour moi aussi le point
sur lequel il faudrait renforcer
renforcer je dirais la présence de de de
de de magistrats qui permettent
véritablement à ce que lorsqu'il y a une
incivilité vis-à-vis d'un élu qu'elle
soit traitée très rapidement les élus
locaux insiste enfin sur l'indispensable
suivi psychologique des victimes le
gouvernement prévoit de s'appuyer app
sur les associations d'aide aux victimes
pour offrir un accompagnement
psychologique aux élus et à leurs
proches en cas d'agression anne-
Françoise piedalu on va commencer par
votre témoignage vous avez été victime
de violence votre voiture a été sabotée
il y a 7 mois racontez-nous ce que vous
avez vécu oui ben écoutez ça remonte en
effet à 7 mois c'était je m'apprêtais à
me rendre à la commémoration du 8 mai en
tant que maire et j'ai découvert mon
véhicule qui affichait heureusement que
j'ai ce systèmelà qui affichait que mes
freins et dysfonctionné donc j'ai pensé
que c'était une panne tout simplement de
mon véhicule mais en fait quand il a été
amené au garage là on m'a appelé en me
disant que les quatre freins avaient les
quatre flexibles de frein avaient été
sectionnés de façon très franche donc
c'était chez moi enfin pas dans mon
garage mais dans ma propriété alors là
étonnement alors il y avait un contexte
déjà qui existait qui était très tendu
hein parce que j'avais déjà eu des
menaces de mort et de mettre le feu à la
mairie 15 jours avant et là j'avais pas
fait de dépô dépôt de plainte al
pourquoi j'avais pas fait un dépôt de
plainte ça c'est la question que les
élus aussi se posent il y a des moment
voilà et donc dépôt de plainte cette
fois là et depuis donc c'est j'en suis à
ma 3è à mon 3è dépôt de plainte
ent-etemps il y a eu l'IDE de menace de
mort qui est arrivé et puis tag
injurieux sur la commune et des faits
réguliers de tension donc ces violences
ne s'arrêtent pas est-ce que selon vous
la réponse judiciaire est assez rapide
alors il y a eu donc le procureur très
vite à saisi donc un magistrat il y a
donc une instruction en cours qui donc a
saisi nous on est sur un
registre gendarme gendarmerie puisqu'on
est dans des petites communes donc ce
sont des gendarmes qui sont mes
interlocuteurs il y a une brigade de
recherche qui est habilité pour faire
toutes les instructions les auditions et
les différents mesures que le magistrat
prend pour essayer de trouver les
auteurs martial foco est-ce qu' a vécu
la mère de la presquille de grescance ça
illustre bien ce phénomène au niveau
national de hausse des violences contre
les élus et là les chiffres sont sans
appel oui à la fois ce que l'on peut
observer dans le cadre de cette enquête
on voit que c'est une progression depuis
2020 parce que finalement je dirais
avant l'été 2019 et et la mort
dramatique du maire de
CNE personne aucune autorité aucun
service de l'État n'avait pris la mesure
de ce phénomène qui est existait déjà
mais dont on avait beaucoup de mal à le
documenter et je me souviens qu'après ce
drame effectivement l'association des
mères de France a a décidé de de mettre
sur pied un dispositif pour documenter
recenser désormais le ministère de
l'intérieur est en situation de nous
donner des chiffres parce qu'il faut
être très à la fois très prudent hein
c'est une grande variété de faits de
violence on va des situations les plus
dramatiques avec des agressions
physiques à des choses plus insidieuses
et vous évoquiez les inivilités
effectivement l'enquête montre que 7 mè
sur 10 depuis leur prise de fonction en
juin 2020 ont déjà subi au moins une
fois une forme d'incivilité et bien
souvent jusqu'alors les maires face à
des incivilités n'avaient pas le réflexe
de signaler de déposer plainte une main
courante or aujourd'hui je crois qu'on
on a une prise de conscience collective
que l'incivilité c'est souvent la
première étape de situations qui peuvent
devenir plus dramatiques euh l'enquête
montre que 7 % 7 % ça peut paraître peu
mais si on le projette sur l'ensemble
des mairres 7 % ayant déjà connu une
agression physique ou qui porte à leur
intégrité physique c'est considérable
euh et et et on le voit dans d'autres je
dirais d'autres professions alors le
mandat de mère n'est pas une profession
mais on voit sur un certain nombre de
représentants de l'autorité publique que
ces chiffres doivent nous alerter sur
effectivement une réponse pas simplement
sur sur le volet répressif mais aussi
sur le volet judiciaire parce que ce que
votre reportage a indiqué et ce que vous
indiquez Madame la Maire c'estàdire que
selon les départements vous avez une
réponse plus ou moins rapide ou plus ou
moins lente des procureurs et surtout
les maires attendent des des des
éléments de réponse de compréhension
parce que c'est pas toujours un délit
parfois ça ne peut être qu'un rappel à
la loi mais encore faut-il communiquer
avec les principaux concernés maire mais
l'ensemble des conseillers municipaux
parce que
dans dans ce travail du ministère de
l'intérieur on n'arrive pas encore bien
à établir le nombre de conseillers
municipaux eux-mêmes exposés à ces
violences André léel d'abord pour faire
le constat on évoquera après la réponse
à apporter pour protéger nos élus sur le
constat quand on voit cette année des
domiciles d'élus attaqués incendiés
est-ce que vous dites là on a franchi un
cap dans ces violences contre des élus
de la République bien sûr mais il y a
des violences j'allais dire de nature
différente ce qui ne veut pas dire que
les les unes excusent les autres mais il
y a bon j'allais dire le manque de
citoyenneté de beaucoup de
malheureusement de nos concitoyens il y
a les injures et puis il y a les actes
physiques ou les attentats parce que je
considère que ce que vous venez de nous
dire relève d'un attentat à votre égard
j'ai moi-même par le passé eu des choses
de même nature à la fois des tags
injurieux sur mon domicile et 3 jours
après une balle qu'on a retrouvé dans ma
salle à manger bon alors heureusement
j'y étais pas mais je veux dire c'est
quand même tout à fait symbolique et
symptomatique d'une montée d'un certain
nombre de manifestations de violence qui
touchent les élus mais je veux élargir
le propos et Martial fouo vient de le
faire c'est tous ceux qui ont un
semblant d'autorité qui sont touchés on
on voit j'allais dire des agressions
physiques à l'égard des sapeurs pompiers
quand ils vont essayer d'éteindre un feu
on voit les agressions à l'égard du
personnel médical parce que ça n'irait
pas assez vite et que les urgences
serait un peu défaillante on voit les
parents d'élèves qui s'en prennent aux
enseignants je vais arrêter mon
énumération mais on voit bien que dès
que dès l'instant où quelqu'un a un
semblant d'autorité ou en tout cas une
capacité de décision si ça ne se fait
pas assez vite si ça se fait pas
exactement comme les gens l'attendent
alors il y a des réactions qui
aujourd'hui sont complètement
disproportionné par rapport évidemment à
la réalité du du problème qui les a
généré Cécile cuckerman vous êtes
d'accord c'est violence contre nos mères
ça traduit plus largement une crise de
l'autorité dans notre République mais je
crois que nous avons aussi de plus en
plus de violence parce que d'abord notre
société est plus violente et elle est au
quotidien et inévitablement quand nous
sommes dans une crise de l'autorité et
et à la fois d' d'une ambigué parce que
le maire est certainement le le
personnage po politique préféré des
Français et donc paradoxalement celui
qui incarne le mieux cette autorité qui
permet et compris de faire République
donc quand il y a cette cassure de la
relation d'autorité mais qui est en fait
une relation de la crise de confiance
qui se fragilise et qui fragilise tout
un chacun inévitablement celui qui reste
en proximité celui qui reste finalement
le cataliseur aussi de de tous les
problèmes de de la vie de nombre de nos
concitoyens de ce besoin de répondre
vite en urgence de manière d'illeurs
très individuelle et qui paradoxalement
est dépossédé de plus en plus de
capacité à agir pour répondre aux
besoins de leur population devient le
maire donc je je crois que nous devons
agir parce que d'abord nous avons besoin
de protéger les élus ça c'est
indispensable nous avons besoin de
protéger les élus aussi dans dans cette
capacité qu'ils ont à représenter la
République dans l'ensemble des communes
de notre pays et donc à ne pas laisser
s'installer le S sentiment que les élus
pourraient demain être les punching
balls de tout un chacun et sur des
raisons et vous le démontrez d'ailleurs
très bien dans l'études qui sont parfois
très diverses très différentes mais qui
Infiné font que oui nous avons de plus
en plus d'élus agressés et il y a besoin
je crois aussi d'une réponse judiciaire
à la hauteur moi je prends dans mon
département j'ai en tête le cas d'un
maire d'une commune l'agression remonte
maintenant à il y a 6 ans il il n'y a
toujours pas eu de suite j'ai envie de
dire je ne veux pas une justice
expéditive ou une loi du talon demain
dans notre pays mais mais mais mais on a
aussi besoin de rappeler que
effectivement ces élus doivent être
protégés accompagnés sécurisés au
quotidien dans l'exercice de leur mandat
on va écouter un autre témoignage d'un
mare d'une commune de pcalais du pcalais
c'était ce matin dans ce congrès des
mères- de France et il témoignait sur
les violences dont il a été victime j'ai
été insulté mes employés aussi au début
de l'année mais avec menace de brûler la
mairie j'ai déposé plainte la personne
est passée très rapidement au tribunal
elle a été condamnée à 4 mois et surc
elle a quitté le département
elle neffectuera jamais sa peine elle
est partie ailleurs elle recommencera et
puis en partant elle m'a fait un beau
bras d'honneur en disant je
t'emmerde on peut espérer son
cas je suis 9 j'ai fait un mandat de
conseiller municipal un mandat d'adjoint
c'est mon 4e mandat de MRE ça n'a jamais
été aussi difficile Anne Françoise
piedalux vous diriez qu'il y a un
laxisme judiciaire face à ces violences
contre les élus alors moi je vais me
référer à ce qui me concerne ce que donc
du coup je vis et ce que je pour lequel
je peux mieux répondre il y a la vitesse
de la justice et il y a ce qui se passe
sur le terrain c'estàd quand je dis ce
qui se passe sur le terrain c'estàdire
que moi en en tant que mère je suis
toujours dans ma commune j'ai à gérer
toujours la commune et les faits se
poursuivent c'estàd qu'on n'est pas dans
une situation de sérénité on a des actes
de malveillance régulière j'ai envie de
dire tous les 15 jours semaine ou tous
les 15 jours des pneus crevés 121 pneus
crevés donc il y a une tension sur la
commune les gens commence aussi à être
fatigué de cette situation je les
comprends moi-même je suis fatiguée
et la justice elle fait ses enquêtes et
on n pas pour l'instant je rebondis un
peu sur ce que vous disiez bon moi ça
fait pas 6 ans du tout je pense pas que
ça sera du tout le cas ça fait 7 mois
mais pour moi ça paraît énorme 7 mois
c'est une c'est énorme 7 mois sans
savoir réellement ce qu'il y a dans le
dossier c'està-dire qu'au final je n'ai
pas connaissance de ce qu'il y a dans le
dossier j'ai dû prendre un avocat
évidemment ça m'a été mais même avec un
avocat j'ai pas accès au dossier martial
fou il y a ces violences qui sont bien
réelles et il y a aussi ce sentiment
d'insécurité de la part de nos élus face
à ces faits c'est un point qu'on retient
dans l'étude du CV P aussi voilà cette
inquiétude qui est en train de monter
oui l'idée c'était de d'aller au-delà de
ce que l'on peut parfois difficilement
objectiver hein on est sur une enquête
déclarative
importante hein plus de 6000 maires ont
répondu à à cette enquête et donc on a
souhaité un petit peu comme cela se fait
quand on interroge les Français sur les
questions de sécurité et vous vous
souvenez des débats il y a près de 20
ans pour une élection présidentielle sur
la mesure objective et la mesure
subjective de l'insécurité donc on a
interroger les maires sur un sentiment
d'insécurité indépendamment du fait
qu'ils aient subi ou non des violences
et donc l'enquête montre
qu'effectivement 15 % des maires
aujourd'hui estiment exercer leur mandat
dans un climat d'insécurité personnel
ils le vivent ainsi euh et on a pu
constater que ce ce ce chiffre en
quelque sorte
était double doublé lorsque les mares
avaient subi l'une de ces formes de
violence alors vous allez me dire c'est
totalement totologique non on va un peu
plus loin dans l'analyse on démontre que
quel que soit finalement la violence
subit qu'elle soit extrêmement grave on
a parlé des violences physiques des
choses plus insidieuses on a parlé des
incivilités mais je rajouterai aussi un
élément moi qui me semble très
préoccupant parce qu'on voit une
progression ce sont les attaques les
intimidations sur les réseaux sociaux
euh face auquel finalement les maires
ont beaucoup de difficultés parce que je
rappelle le réseau social c'est c'est
pas un réseau social personnel c'est
souvent un réseau social institutionnel
c'est celui de la mairie qui permet de
véhiculer des informations des activités
de la commune et bien ça sert un peu
d'exutoire d'un certain nombre de
d'habitants de citoyens de la commune ou
de l'extérieur je je j'ai en tête cette
histoire dans le Tarne ce petit village
de monjois où le maire a vu finalement
un un influenceur venir rassembler une
communauté pour le menacer le diffamer
en quelque sorte et là la question qui
se pose et je pense que c'est une
question qui doit engager une réponse
aussi de l'état euh c'est une formation
indispensable dans l'usage des réseaux
sociaux parce que la réaction naturelle
des ma est d'essayer finalement par le
dialogue par les médiations d'essayer
d'apporter des réponses mais encore une
fois j'insiste sur ce point tous les
maires ne disposent pas des mêmes
ressources pour pouvoir y répondre que
ce soit sur les réseaux sociaux et d'une
manière générale vis-à-vis de ces formes
d'inciivilité et de violence alors qu'on
voit sur vos images et bien les maires
qui arrivent à l'Élysée le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron je le
rappelle va recevoir ce soir 1000 maires
dans le cadre et bien en tout cas
pendant cette semaine du Congrès des
Maires de France alors qu'on le rappelle
Emmanuel Macron a décidé de ne pas venir
cette semaine au Congrès des Maires de
France on poursuit notre débat Andr lel
je voudrais que vous rebondissiez sur ce
que disait martial fou c'est vrai
qu'auparavant on avait cette image du
maire comme médiateur qui pouvait régler
les problèmes sur le terrain avec ses
administrés par le dialogue quand on
voit cette violence qui se catalyse
notamment avec les réseaux sociaux ce
maire médiateur c'est plus possible et
pourtant nous continuons à le faire
chaque jour mais c'est plus risqué parce
que c'est nécessaire mais ce qui est
vrai c'est que nous sommes de plus en
plus souvent en première ligne si vous
revenez à la crise sanitaire qui est-ce
qui a été en première ligne pour les
masques bah on pouvait pas distribuer à
tout le monde en même temps mais ceux
avec qui on nait pas distribué en
premier venez nous dire mais pourquoi
nous on est abandonné pendant que vous
distribuez ailleurs quand nous sommes
dans la vaccination on a les mêmes
problématiques c'est nous qui sommes en
première ligne parce que l'État est aux
abonnés absents mais en même temps on
nous dit oui mais alors vous avez
commencé par vacciner tel quartier
pourquoi vous avez commencer par eux je
schématise mais quand vous êtes en
première ligne que vous répondez à
l'urgence de vos concitoyens et que vous
n'avez pas forcément les moyens de
répondre à leur urgenceah ils s'en
prennent à la proximité la proximité
c'est le maire ou les conseillers
municipaux ou les adjoints parce que
malheureusement on parle des maires mais
je voudrais rappeler que c'est
l'ensemble de l'institution communale y
compris le personnel de nos communes qui
est souvent prise à parti par des
citoyens alors heureusement c'est plus
souvent verbal que
physique mais bien entendu c'est plus
grave quand c'est physique mais c'est
pas plus acceptable quand c'est verbal
et nous savons bien que j'allais dire on
a souvent dit que les élus locaux
étaient apportés de BAFF les services
publics locaux aussi et pourtant c'est
ce qui est essentiel pour le vivre
ensemble et quand il y a atteinte à ceux
qui font vivre le service public local
qu'il soit élu ou personnel territoriale
c'est évidemment totalement inacceptable
parce que sans eux alors notre pays
serait une jungle Cécile cuckerman on va
évoquer les solutions qu'on peut mettre
en œuvre pour mieux protéger nos élus
face à ces violences le Sénat le mois
dernier a voté une proposition de loi
avec des mesures et notamment des
sanctions plus fermes c'est un texte qui
aligne aligne les sanctions pénales
prévues pour les auteurs de violence
contre les élus sur les sanctions
prévues pour les auteurs par exemple
contre de violence contre les forces de
l'ordre la sanction la fermeté c'est
d'abord un premier signal à envoyer
d'abord je crois que nous et notre
groupe avons bien évidemment voté cette
proposition elle est une des réponses
mais je crois que ne nous trompons pas
ça ne peut pas être la seule réponse et
ce ne sera pas la solution parce que si
je prends le cas de Madame parce que
vous êtes sur le plateau mon objectif
est tout de même d'empêcher qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui un jour puisse se dire
qu'on a le droit dans ce pays d'aller
couper les freins de la voiture du maire
parce que on tant mieux et on doit
arrêter cette personne et elle doit être
sanctionné au regard de la gravité des
faits et donc si nous devons renforcer
bien évidemment les sanction pénale
faisons-le mais ayons aussi une
réflexion un peu plus large et globale
sur comment est-ce que non pas nous en
rayons mais en tout cas nous puissions
endiguer davantage que ce n'est le cas
aujourd'hui l'ensemble de ces violences
à l'égard des élus parce que ce qui
vient d'être dit je crois est très
important la vraie difficulté que nous
allons avoir demain c'est que si nous
avons des élus qui sont dans ce
sentiment réel subi ou ou supposé
d'insécurité nous allons nous retrouver
dans une vraie crise démocratique le
propre des élus et notamment dans une
démocratie représentative c'est de
récupérer ce pouvoir des citoyens et
donc d'être en lien permanent avec eux
pour décider pour aménager pour faire
les médiations nécessaires pour répondre
aux besoins de la population si demain
ce sentiment d'insécurité continue de
grandir chez les
élus nous pouvons aussi avoir un autre
phénomène c'est des élus qui infé se
repli sur eux-mêm et n'osent plus être
dans ce lien là donc je crois que c'est
un vrai défi nous avons répondu au Sénat
sur la question du renforcement des
sanctions et et je n'ai aucune
difficulté à être dans ce registre là en
revanche nous avons besoin maintenant de
continuer de travailler collectivement
sur plus largement comment nous
redonnons légitimité autorité capacité à
faire aux élus locaux pour pouvoir être
respecté par la population demain Anne
François piedalu selon vous quel sont
les solutions à mettre en œuvre pour
mieux protéger les élus et renforcer
cette autorité que représente le maire
alors sur cette question je trouve qu'il
y a une sorte de paradoxe malgré tout
parce que bon les les habitants les
administrés alors pas tous mais
globalement quand même ça a été dit il y
a une plus grande exigence une
impatience quand il y a des demandes qui
sont formulées qui arrivent en mairie la
plupart du temps auprès du maire en
fonction aussi de la strate de la la
commune et plus la commune est plus est
petite et plus on est près du maire j'ai
envie de dire donc là toute réponse qui
va pas dans le sens de l' administré
parce qu'on peut pas toujours aller dans
le sens de l'administré selon les
dossiers qui sont traités par exemple
l'urbanisme on peut pas toujours donner
un accord favorable quand c'est justifié
évidemment ça donc ils ont du mal à
l'entendre à l'accepter mais
paradoxalement à ça je prends l'exemple
de la tempête donc fait tout récent là
bah les élus on a été évidemment
complètement embarqué et ça fait partie
tout à fait de notre rôle et là les les
habitants venaient nous trou en nous
disant c'est à vous de faire alors
remettez l'électricité non c'est
éédis remettez le téléphone non c'est
Orange et en fait faut renvoyer
régulièrement le fait que amère non il a
pas toute compétences dans tous les
domaines alors ce qui est paradoxal
c'est que d'un côté on nous critique
quand on prend ce qui est de notre
compétence et sur lequel on agit et
quand ce n'est pas notre compétence on
vient nous trouver et on nous demande
d'intervenir et je je trouve que c'est
un petit peu étrange martial fouco
l'enjeu c'est peut-être de casser cette
image de la part des administrés du
maire qui peut tout faire qui peut
répondre à tout avec cette exigence des
citoyens qui est de plus en plus forte
et qui parfois se traduit en violence
oui je je dirais que sur la sur la les
causes de ces violences on ne fait que
démarrer ce travail parce que
véritablement on a une très très grande
variété de causes elles sont pas
simplement liées je dirais l'incivisme
on parlait de l'incivisme on pourit dire
c'est une question d'éducation oui c'est
une question d'éducation mais pas
seulement parce que vous avez aussi des
comportements qui sont liés à une très
grande précarité sociale d'un grand
nombre de de citoyens d'habitants pour
qui d'ailleurs je dirais que la
connaissance de ce qu'est la compétence
ou les compétences d'un mur va bien
au-delà de je dirais de vieux cours à
l'école primaire ou au collège
premièrement deuxièmement même s'il y
avait une connaissance ce qui n'est pas
le cas euh aujourd'hui dans ce pays sur
ce quel est véritablement le champ
d'intervention d'un maire il faut bien
voir que cette exigence dite
démocratique d'un citoyen vis-à-vis du
maire c'est parce que il reste l'élu de
proximité et c'est aussi pour cela que
cet élu euh est aujourd'hui le
représentant en qui on a le plus
confiance donc je vous rejoins il y a il
y a une forme de paradoxe puis je
rajouterai un dernier point puisque vous
vous discutiez des des des propositions
qui permettraient de d'enrayer cette
cette dynamique je je pense que et vous
l'avez dit he madame la sénatrice on
peut difficilement
on aurait pu difficilement considérer
que ce degré très
conflictuel la conflictualisation de la
société française laisser les communes
totalement
imperméable à ce niveau de conflit et
aujourd'hui je dirais que la la
polarisation de la vie politique
rejaillit également sur les élus et sur
les comportements qui sont jugés
légitimes par les citoyens parce qu'il
ne considère pas immédiatement qu'il est
illégitime d'apostropher d'insulter ou
de menacer un élu André léniel pour
conclure cette émission il nous reste 30
secondes je voudrais finir par une
question politique on le voit là les
maires arrivent à l'Élysée ils sont
invités ce soir par le Président de la
République vous en tant que premier
vice-président de l'AMF vous avez refusé
d'y aller pour quelle raison parce que
moi je suis élu pour travailler pas pour
aller déguster des coupes de champagne
et des petits fours donc chaque fois que
on souhaite TR que je participe à une
réunion de travail je répondrai présent
s'il s'agit simplement de servir de
faire valoir au président de la
République je ne serai jamais présent on
finira par ces mots merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat tout de suite c'est
l'heure de votre émission sens public
Thomas HUG et ses invités vont revenir
sur l'accord conclu entre Israël et le
Hamas pour la libération de 50 otages et
une trêve de 4 jours dans ce conflit
très bonne soirée sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]
voir ou revoir votre
programme sur
publsena.fr tout de suite sur public
[Musique]
SNA bonjour bonjour j'ai besoin de
penser ma table vous prendriez laquelle
vous ben j'en prendrai
pas comment ça j'en achèterai pas vous
êtes bizarre